alguien fue misionero Sí en Finlandia
puedes decir algo en finlandés
hospital
soy un tipo de pocas palabras
juntamos a siete mormonas O creyentes de
los Santos de los Últimos Días soy
miembro soy miembro soy miembro soy
miembro de la iglesia de los Santos de
los Últimos Días Uno de ellos es un
impostor si el grupo descubre Quién es
el impostor ganarán el premio en
efectivo
si el impostor sobrevive se llevará todo
el dinero
Quién es el impostor
podemos empezar preguntando desde hace
cuánto forman parte de la iglesia les
parece
desde que nací soy salía y pueden
llamarme sal me uní a la iglesia cuando
cumplí 10 años lo hice antes que mi mamá
de hecho y me bautizaron antes que ella
creo que ya son 8 años soy sabana y soy
parte desde que nací igual soy Elizabeth
misma historia que Sabana heiden desde
que nací soy Caleb desde que nací y han
pasado 19 años desde que me bautizaron
me llamo Natalie y formó parte desde
siempre empezamos malo no creo que lo
importante es averiguar quién tiene
conocimientos de la iglesia deberíamos
mencionar un pasaje de las escrituras y
explicar por qué nos gusta de acuerdo Yo
empiezo me gusta Morón y 737 estaba en
mi placa de misionero creo que dice algo
como es por la fe que se obran los
milagros Y si los milagros son cesado es
por falta de fe me gusta mucho porque me
ayuda a recordar que los milagros sí
suceden no recuer o el versículo Exacto
dice que eso no me ayuda en nada Creo
que está en el capítulo 12 de en Netflix
o cerca de ahí me gusta porque la
primera vez que lo leí me emocioné la
última frase me marcó cuando el profeta
dice que decía estas palabras
representan la verdad libro del Mormón
tiene muchos capítulos y no mencionó
ningún detalle en específico parece que
no supiera la diferencia tengo el mismo
problema no recuerdo muy bien Cuál era
el capítulo decía una ciudad asentada
sobre un monte no se puede esconder no
está en Mateo por supuesto está en Mateo
y la escuché en la secundaria cuando
vivía en Oregón Y era una de las pocas
mormonas de la ciudad la frase me hizo
sentir que debía ser un ejemplo para el
resto de los mormones que vivían en la
ciudad no sé por qué
diciendo Mormón sin parar en nuestra
iglesia insistimos mucho en el hecho de
que Mormón no es nuestro nombre oficial
voté por ella porque no recordaba el
pasaje
tenía el presentimiento de que me
eliminarían porque no logré recordar
nada y solo me congele alguien fue
misionero Sí yo en Italia
puedes decir algo en finlandés
bien Creo que me toca a mí
anciano
Yo decía Hola Soy misionero soy un tipo
de pocas palabras y si mencionamos cuál
fue nuestra conferencia favorita de la
semana pasada vi una parte de los
mensajes del profeta para el seminario
pero no lo escuché completo 30 Estamos
celebrando mi cumpleaños
cada seis meses en Octubre y abril hay
algo que se llama conferencia general
donde el presidente de la iglesia y los
otros líderes dan diferentes charlas es
muy importante que todos la sintonicen
para escuchen lo que el señor quiere
decir un aspecto importante de nuestras
religiones que creemos que actualmente
hay un profeta entre nosotros amo las
charlas Elder Holland sobre la Salud
Mental y Cómo podemos mejores personas
si nos preguntamos que atraviesan los sí
me encanta cuando hablan sobre eso
porque me cuesta mantener mi salud me
alegra que ahora hay muchas charlas
sobre Salud Mental siento que son muy
importantes y que se está dejando de
lado el estilo todo sienten que como
mormones Oh perdón como la iglesia de
Jesucristo y los santos de los últimos
días mi profesor de seminario me
regañaría por decir esto nombre es largo
y lo siento son muchas palabras quería
saber si sienten que los criaron con
valores que no compartían en realidad o
si creen que sus valores se alinean con
la iglesia ahora no sé si lo notaron
pero tengo un tatuaje y unas cuantas
perforaciones
cuando era joven tuve una etapa Rebelde
Porque muchos de mis valores no
coincidían con los de la iglesia mi fe
en El Salvador siempre ha sido muy
fuerte y sé que mientras la tenga estaré
bien y formaré parte te alejaste un poco
y luego regresaste Sí exactamente me
alejé e hice una búsqueda espiritual te
entiendo justo ahora estoy en una fase
inactiva de mí camino religioso siento
que también estoy atravesando una
búsqueda espiritual reflexiones es
importante es verdad
se alejó de la iglesia por un tiempo es
sospechoso
tenemos un empate de tres
el empate es entre Natalie está bien
Elizabeth de acuerdo y sal cada una
tendrá 30 segundos para defender su caso
no sé qué decir soy mormona mi película
favorita es el regreso del Mormón porque
representa muy bien nuestra vida y
cultura mormona no sé qué más decirles
doy clases de religión a niños los
domingos fuese la impostora hubiese
cubierto mi tatuaje y mis perforaciones
para no llamar la atención y
confundirlos me bautizaron a los 8 mi
hermano fue sellado en el templo bautizo
a los muertos con regularidad y tengo
una recomendación al templo para
defenderme recitaré El lema de las
mujeres jóvenes somos hijas del padre
que nos ama y amamos somos sus testigos
en todo lugar y momento mientras vivimos
en los valores de las mujeres que son fe
naturaleza divina trabajo conocimiento
elección responsabilidad buen trabajo
integridad y virtud fortaleceremos
nuestro hogar haremos votos sagrados
recibiremos las ordenanzas del templo y
disfru sus bendiciones
[Música]
Lo siento
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue dentro de la caja y
quieren continuar el juego Tengo tantas
cosas que preguntarte
mucho educar a la audiencia tengo algo
que nos ayudará a continuar la
conversación me preguntaba si alguno
podría compartir un momento que los
ayudó a asegurarse que nuestra fe es
verdadera mi abuelo falleció este mes
hace cuatro años y era el único abuelo
que me quedaba con vida un día mientras
le pedía al Señor fortaleza para seguir
sentí que mi corazón se llenó de tanto
afecto y supe que lo vería de nuevo que
ya les comenté que fui la primera
persona que bautizaron en mi iglesia
tenía solo 10 años y significó mucho
para mí no hablo de lo que sentí en ese
momento sino de los cambios que ves mi
familia era ruidosa y problemática nunca
tenía paz en casa pero en cuanto les
transmití todo lo que hoy en día mi
hogar se convirtió en un lugar Pacífico
y tranquilo podría preguntarles acerca
de los periodos de inactividad que
atraviesan ahora podrían explicar con
más profundidad del tipo de dudas que
tenían en mi caso Está muy relacionado
con el hecho de que tengo una ideología
política de izquierda y muchos de esos
valores no se alinean con lo que la
iglesia nos enseña a lo largo de
nuestras vidas por eso me alejé en
verdad necesitaba encontrar una manera
de mantener mis creencias y mi fe porque
creo que es importante tratar a todos
con amor solo así logré entender que
votar por alguien en específico no
significa que no crea en la palabra mi
caso es más personal necesito revaluar
mi forma de pensar porque creo que mi
visión ha cambiado creo que cuando te
alejas un poco de tu religión logras ver
con Claridad las diferencias entre vivir
en la palabra y no hacerlo luego de
alejarme me di cuenta que me sentía
mejor antes fue una experiencia muy
importante para mí porque afiancé mis
creencias
tengo mis sospechas sobre Clay no
entiendo bien Por qué se alejó de su fe
y Sé que suena hipócrita de mi parte
Adiós Cleo Adiós adiós
impostor sigue dentro de la caja y
quieren continuar el juego
si se encienden las luces verdes
significa que eliminaron al impostor y
ganaron si se encienden Rojas El
impostor sigue en la caja y perdieron
[Aplausos]
impostor da un paso al frente en tres
dos
uno
seguro en todas las ondas sabía que
tenías razón
y no se inmutó era una de las pocas
mormonas de la ciudad nuestra vida y
cultura mormona empecé a tener dudas
sobre la iglesia antes de ir a la
universidad Y dije Oh lo que predicó y
lo que en verdad siento no es lo mismo
me inclino mucho a la izquierda política
y en lo que dejé la iglesia me di cuenta
de que Oh era gay ni siquiera podía
pensar en eso cuando era miembro de la
iglesia porque en la cabeza no existía
la posibilidad pero ahora soy muy feliz
y vivo en California si eres parte de la
comunidad miembro de la iglesia y
alguien te ama hay un lugar para ti no
importa si es dentro o fuera de la
iglesia puedas hacer todo lo que quieras
hacer y necesites hacer para ser feliz
me alegra mucho tener la oportunidad de
hablar de mi experiencia con la iglesia
y me gusta que las personas puedan ver
esto y nuestras historias Porque todos
compartimos puntos de vista válidos los
miembros de la iglesia intentamos seguir
el camino del Salvador y mientras lo
hacemos creo que nos parecemos un poco
más a él yo espero que a medida que
crezcamos como personas seamos capaces
de mostrarles a otros que si los amamos
por como son
creo que deberíamos es el momento
Gracias hay que hacer sus bolsillos
terminamos chicos nos merecíamos el
premio
esperen tengo más bolsillos